[Music]
we're interested in the big questions in
biology
[Music]
all of the animals that colonize this
area had to go through incredible amount
of change in order to live in this
unique environment hey hey hey hang on
it's all so exciting and this time when
our world is changing really rapidly and
we want to know whether and how and when
animals are going to be able to adapt to
environmental changes I'm gonna get a
GPS point over here too
[Music]
some people just use a simple Slipknot
but I like the slip knot in the slip
knot
[Music]
and so what we see is that a lot of the
animals have evolved a number of
different adaptations to survive here
the most noticeable one is that they're
all incredibly light in color
and you see that the white sands one is
a lot lighter in color than the one from
down the road you can also see that it's
stripes on its back or much fainter
it's incredibly important for them to be
camouflaged in their environment because
they are out looking for their food and
looking to find mates and doing all the
things that lizards do during the day
and at the same time they're predators
are out looking for food and all the
things the Predators do during the day
[Music]
we measure what color they are we
measure different aspects of their body
size we measure what they're eating the
same gene that is involved in the color
difference in these lizards is also a
gene that's involved in color variation
even in humans they'll be a puppy
[Music]
[Music]